Bracey he's gonna penetrate evening
civilized towns you look a man direct in
the face when you talk to him
this isn't comfortable no it's not
supposed to be there's a situation
serious mrs. O'Dwyer was abducted she is
my everything and those savages of
Goddard God knows what they're doing to
her every second if we delay you know
did this you don't have a name how many
of you think there are won't matter you
have no chance gets any number Luke I'm
coming with you no no I need you here
this way two backups for to help an
emergency not stay back I'm coming we're
making a five-day journey in three days
riding long asleep in the bare minimal
although it's west of here
Ocala trailer anything else goes in that
direction our horses die before we get
there we go into hostile territory weak
and foggy with exhaustion
we won't rescue anybody
so we scared I am a friend you are you
you had no cause if you want to question
my morals do it later bless us O Lord
and these thy gifts which we are about
to receive
remember
van der Linde velvet named bernzy Duvall
- - the Systema fear